hey everyone here on the free Kirkham
channel in this tutorial I'm going to be
building a tool that every app and
startup should have I'm going to build a
dashboard to let you know if your app
Goes Down And if it does notify you over
email and SMS so in other words a clone
of the popular software as a service app
pages juicy one of the best ways to
learn software development is to create
a slimmed down version of software you
use every day to get a better
understanding of how it might work this
process helps you understand the problem
space constraints and techniques
required to build a real-world use case
pager Duty is awesome as it helps alert
teams to high priority incidents like
web outages or security issues using
pre-configured configuration strategies
and multi-channel notifications
so what are we waiting for let's do it